speaking of endlessly hysterical this is
absolutely hilarious this is actually
incredible I honestly thought it was a
joke when I saw it there is a non-profit
organization here in Florida called
Florida equality there's some sort of
gay
lgbtqi two-spirit whatever organization
and they have issued a statement as of
yesterday this is this is powerful stuff
guys they have issued in Red Letters Red
Letters all caps it doesn't get scarier
than that that's the big one breaking
today we took the extraordinary step of
issuing a travel advisory warning the
risks posed to the health safety and
freedom of those considering short or
long-term travel or relocation to the
state
I want to be very clear about something
guys
if you are a Democrat or a lefty or
liberal take their advice
take their advice don't come here we've
got this thing called Freedom you make
up your own mind when you wake up in the
morning on how you want to live and
they're not going to lock in your house
here and your kids are going to go to
school and we're going to do it all
right here but I know that's scary to
you people so I really want you to heed
the warning of Florida
equality you know the funny thing about
it is Florida equality the group is
called Florida equality so I would
assume they want equality for all
Floridians
which we have which we have I didn't
bother showing you there's like a six
tweet thread of that where they just try
to scare the hell out of everybody
once again guys Florida is not coming
for the gays and they are not coming
even for the trans or anything else what
Florida is do I don't even have to give
it to you you know what Florida is doing
and it's all good
[Music]